look at the DNA of Cairo Knife Fight
you'll find Grammy Awards Emmy Awards
and pure talent here tell us more about
their upcoming show at Sand Dollar
downtown our members George pahone Jr
and Nick Gaffney welcome to the show you
guys thank you for having me it's great
to have you here how would you describe
the sounds of your group
it's uh it's rock but it's got a little
bit of a Twist to it it's uh it's quite
combative it's a little bit um
improvised and exploratory too well your
shows are different too tell us more
about what can we expect when we go to
sand dollar downtown at the at the show
well it's a start it's just two people
we're a Duo so I play guitar and bass he
plays drums sings and plays Bass with
his left hand and for the sand dollar
show we're bringing our good friend Matt
garzka to join us so it'll be two drums
on the stage for that show so two
drummers going back at the same time yes
that's a lot of energy oh yeah and he's
a beast of a drama so I'm gonna try to
keep up how did you guys meet how did
this connection happen I did a recording
and writing session in New Zealand and
met his roommates and when he decided to
move to America he moved into the
backyard of where my studio was this is
that's how you guys came together yeah
and George you you have quite the past
you've worked with sting Santana Ricky
Martin of course you're a member of The
Black Eyed Peas as well Grammys are
coming up on Sunday yes you've won seven
Grammys yes where do you keep all of
your Grammys well it's uh a thing that
most people don't know you only get
statues for as a writer for two
categories song of the year record of
the Year okay so you don't get statues
when you write the song and they're not
under those categories so you want seven
Grammys yeah and you don't have a Grammy
stature in your house
how is that possible you get the medal
which is beautiful sure yeah I want the
statue though I want seven Grammy
statues in my house you could buy them
but to me that's sacrilegious yes you
want it we got to change this yeah when
you when you I mean so many hit songs
you're involved with too when you write
a song and it's done do you know like
that's a hit song do you know right away
it's happened a couple times when we put
strings on where's the love I knew that
one was going to be ahead you knew that
was a hit yeah that's awesome well nick
uh you like working with George George
like working with Nick yeah it's a good
relationship you saw the guys at Magic
Mike out here earlier yes they stole our
bit see they stole your give me
you guys are a lot of fun sand dollar
Lounge downtown it's on Saturday
February 11th the night before the Super
Bowl right yes uh the drum clinic for
Matt Garza starts at 7 p.m and then Matt
will perform with us at 9 30. awesome
beautiful thank you guys for coming on
thank you very much